let's uh open up the mailbag the first
one relates to the new york giants who
are now oh and three kp for three says
the giants looked like they didn't even
belong on the field against an extremely
banged up 49ers team is dave gettleman
the jam of the team on the hot seat or
does ownership have his back knowing
this was going to be a tough year to
begin with shireen what do you think
well you know i question a lot of things
that dave gettleman's done but i do like
the hiring of joe judge i just he's
impressed me with everything he's done
during the training camp the build up he
seemed like he had won over the players
now it hasn't gone right on the field i
get that and daniel jones to me look
like he's regressed he's he's ranked
ahead of only carson wentz there you got
three of the three of the four nfc east
quarterbacks are among the five worst
quarterbacks in the nfl so far and dana
jones has just not looked good uh so far
so i do have some questions obviously
about the way they're playing and the
way they're losing the 49ers had all
those injuries yesterday 31st in offense
and tied for 12th in defense but i think
he has a right coach and i think he's
going to be given more time
because of the fact that the weird
offseason that they had and joe judge
being his first season with this staff
all right i'll just say this before we
move on to the next question
i don't like the idea of firing the gm
and keeping the coach
they've had too many guys on different
tracks and and that that is a sign of
dysfunction with any nfl team because
the new gm is instantly going to want to
hire his own head coach so either keep
them both or get rid of them both
whatever they do after this year and you
shouldn't get rid of them both after
this year another question from the pft
pm policy does arthur blank regret not
firing dan quinn more after the 28-3
super bowl loss after the first half of
last season or after last season ended
should he fire him now
i i
i think that
now what's going on would create regret
that he didn't fire dan quinn at the end
of last season i think that is the right
time to do it because there's no
guarantee
that an interim coach is going to make
the situation any better they've got two
former head coaches on that staff
working for dan quinn dirk cutter the
offensive coordinator who was the coach
of the buccaneers and raheem morris the
defensive coordinator who was the coach
of the buccaneers the defense is
horrendous the offense isn't much better
especially when it's time to hold a lead
i don't know that you definitely make
the team better or you even remotely
make the team better by getting rid of
dan quinn i feel like in a year like
this where you have the benefit of not
having to worry about fans who won't
show up because they're not going to
show up anyway for the most part i think
you just ride it out and you get the
right coach presumably an offensive head
coach after the season ends all right um
real quick point before we move on to
the monday night game mike mccarthy the
cowboys coach said within the hour that
he does not believe tristan hill had
intent to injure chris carson he was
just simply trying to tackle him and
that was part of the tackling maneuver i
don't buy it mccarthy's saying what he
has to say i i think it's baloney i
think you know you either trust what the
people are saying or you trust your
lying eyes shireen does it change at all
for you that mccarthy is defending
tristan hill no
no and i i think he probably went over
his locker room and went over tristan
hill saying that but anybody who watched
that play i don't think you can watch
the play and not think it's a dirty play
i don't know if i'm in the locker room i
don't know how i feel about it because i
don't want guys tackling me that way
from other teams and you're opening the
door for that to happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports